hello everyone and welcome back to some
daily rapid action unleashes I took a
break from all the rapid games that I
was playing uh due to the coverage of
the of the Tata still chess tournament
but now that finished and while we're
waiting for the next big event um I will
probably go back to playing one game a
day uh and uh uploading it for you guys
to enjoy so it's uh mostly tailored to
lower rated players um to to give you an
example of what to consider on every
move what what to think about not so
much as okay let's play a certain line
that we know how to play and then we win
the game but how to approach any
position uh regardless of what your
opponent plays even if you don't know
the line as I most often do not know the
lines so let's check it out we're
playing 10 minutes per player uh 0er
seconds increment and uh I I did lose a
little bit of rating I tried to play
while I was watching the Tata still but
uh you know then I'm my attention is
sort of uh uh shifts from from the
coverage to my game and the games are
not as high in quality as they are as
when I'm you
know solely playing for the purpose of
recording and explaining my moves so we
are going to uh play E4 as we usually do
we take the the center we're going to
reply to knight uh to E5 with Knight to
F3 we attack the pawn he defends the
pawn and we're going to play Bishop to
C4 where okay uh sometimes they go for
for the Italian sometimes for for Knight
to F6 uh the two knights defense and
we're going to attack head on the best
way is to go after the the F7 Pawn
unless you're like 2600 then you play C3
so we're going to play we're not 2600 so
we're going to play Knight to G5 uh and
we're going to uh play this so okay we
have to capture here our opponent
attacks the bishop and we're going to
play Bishop to B5 with check so uh if
you play this line it's kind of a line
that you have to know uh here you can go
back with Bishop to D2 Bishop to D3 you
can play Queen to F3 uh these are all
very very standard lines uh I tried
playing Queen F3 and Bishop to D3 I I'm
really bad at it so I just stick with
the oldest possible way and that is
Bishop to E2 and there's not much to
explain here as this is uh if you play
the two knights defense and if you play
the the Knight to G5 attack then this is
a line that you have to know uh it's uh
you
know uh best by test so to say and now
your opponent will further attack the
Knight while developing his pieces
something like um Bishop D6 or queen to
C7 will put pressure on the Knight and
our goal is to Castle our King to safety
play B3 maybe put our Bishop on this
diagonal as he will cast The King side
and uh enjoy his extra enjoy our extra
Pawn that's kind of the idea here okay
so Bishop to D6 not sure how to counter
it uh probably F4 is better than D4 but
I also could be wrong D4 could be better
than F4 uh as I don't know the
difference I'm just going to play F4 uh
and later on we're going to play B3
castles Knight to C3 and figure out how
to
develop all right and he will of course
try to make use of his
um uh sort of lead in development to put
pressure on my position before I can
consolidate and enjoy my extra Pawn
that's kind of the idea okay so he will
capture now my is hanging I have to
capture back with the knight uh so
that's what we're going to do he's going
to Castle I'm going to Castle and then
well the the pretty standard stuff
something like B3 Bishop to Bishop to
B2 yeah castles
castles uh probably the bishop is coming
well he he might put it to B7 but I
don't think he will he will go Rook to
B8 most likely and put a knight on
Bishop on F5 or G4 maybe go Rook to E8
uh maybe Queen to C7 I mean I mean there
are so many different ways you could
develop here yeah he's going to go
Bishop to G4 and we're just going to
play B3 we don't care about his Bishop
to G4 move um he doesn't have any
pressure for the moment on our position
he might play something like Queen to C7
to sort of threaten Bishop captures and
then win a pawn here but uh I don't
think it's um it's anything
serious we can just play H3 yes we are
weakening the position over King a
little bit but uh
still uh we up a pawn you know as time
passes by that uh that Advantage will
will uh just grow uh in importance
unless we do something really stupid and
blunder the
game uh but yeah I'm I'm pretty sure you
could say that about any position so
yeah Bishop to B2 is coming is there a
way for him to counter that I don't know
like Bishop captures I don't think you
will ever see a move like this uh we we
still both have the bishop pair so
giving up the bishop for Knight doesn't
really do all that much it's better to
just continue developing Now The Rook uh
doesn't really belong on B8 any anymore
as I've played B3 so yeah he will go for
Bishop to C5 with check uh sort of
stopping me from from going
D4 uh but uh yeah we're we're still
going to play D4 maybe not right away
but yeah not now C3 is coming with the
threat of B4 and well probably after he
figures out what to do with the Knight
here on A5 we're going to play
D4 and then uh Play Bishop to B2 maybe
this is some sort of a an elaborate plan
on how to prevent me from controlling
this diagonal maybe he wants me to play
C3 and then he's going to move the
Knight and then my Bishop will be
looking a little bit silly here okay so
he wants to go for Knight to F2 check uh
definitely makes sense he wants to win
The Rook now the question is can I play
D4 right
away um I mean I could have played it uh
as soon as he played Bishop to C5
probably uh but I wanted to avoid any
any tricky
stuff yeah now we have to be a little
bit careful uh because D4 might run into
Bishop captures but still it it doesn't
really matter yeah Bishop captures we
can capture and if he captures uh on D4
to sort of threaten my Rook let's say I
pick up the Knight he takes the Rook
yeah it doesn't really doesn't really
work
uh doesn't really work so we might even
have to play Queen E1
yeah or we just play D4 and after Bishop
captures on F3 we can play captures and
C 5 but that just uh looks weird I think
for the moment we have to play Queen to
E1 there's no way to to punish Queen T1
so we're just going to play it and we we
avoid all the nasty
stuff unless he has something like Queen
to B6 which I don't think he
does yeah okay so he goes here and now
uh
well now D3 is just
uh D3 just looks very nice D3 attacks
the Knight and also this Knight but once
he moves this Knight he will also be
attacking my Bishop but then after I
capture the Knight I will also be
attacking his Bishop so D3
here yeah I don't think he sort of
uh played this correctly
even if he captures on F3 first I can
even capture with the bishop that's even
better for me no it's not if he captures
with the bishop yeah I capture with the
bishop then KN have to check uh and my
queen is
exposed yeah this is
uh extremely interesting but I still I
still don't think it's good for him
because even if he captures here uh I
can capture the Knight and then if he
captures with the bishop he's not Knight
on A5 oh no the Knight isn't hanging the
Knight is defended by the queen okay
well if the Knight isn't hanging then we
probably
miscalculated a little bit
here yeah I don't know why I thought the
Knight was hanging that's uh yeah that's
a
shame okay it's still not
uh still not a terrible
loss uh since I mean we're still just up
a pawn nothing really changed I just
thought we'd be we' be having more fun
here yeah and he's really really
successful at uh preventing me from
playing this bishop to beat you
move yeah okay now the now the Knight
will move probably to
F6 and then we we go with Bishop to B2
no we don't yeah yeah if Knight F6 we go
Bishop B2 he goes Queen E7 look
looks really
ugly yeah there's no if he goes Knight
back to F6 I have to again unpin with my
queen the question is do I unpin
aggressively or do I oh he goes yeah
he's really preventing me from playing
Bishop to
B2 really nice stuff
here
uh
yeah this is very
interesting but I mean what happens
after C3 not
really not really getting this oh he he
just wants to
capture yeah he just wants to capture
and once I capture he captures I capture
he captures
here and he wins his Pawn back
uh but he will be down in
development I'm guessing or do we have
anything
better yeah I don't think we do I don't
think we
do okay so he takes here I will take
here he will take
there oh no he wants to play Rook no he
oh he could have played Rook captur on
E2 Maybe
yeah very
interesting
okay okay we're up a minute on the clock
so is Bishop to beat you a move or is it
or will he just play something like F6
and then my Bishop here is a is a target
so nothing really happening
here um no I'm thinking I'm thinking
it's for the moment it's
good for the moment it's good he has to
defend it somehow and then we're going
to bring the Rook to F1 and just have a
whole lot of pressure on uh yeah he
still has to figure out what to do with
the Knight otherwise he can't really
develop his Queen so we do have some
time
here uh maybe there are better moves but
I'd like to keep my time Advantage here
yeah so okay he equalized in material uh
I was able to get the bishop to B2 uh
the question is uh is the bishop useful
on B2
now and
um yeah we might be looking at
uh yeah it's hard for him to play I mean
the queen can't move because the Knight
is undefended if he plays Knight B7 he
gives up the C6 Pawn okay he does take
the bishop but we also grab a pawn so
we're we can be up in material
easily so how does he
play not a not a lot of good moves for
him
um yeah I'm guessing he has to go for
night B7 I just don't see a a move other
than Knight to
B7
okay Rook B8 yeah okay I mean no idea
what what that move does but uh yeah I
guess you can play
it
um okay so now
uh yeah I could go Rook F5 attack the
Knight but he then he will move the
Knight or he wants to play Rook B5
that's also an
option yeah Rook B5 actually a pretty
neat way of
developing yeah Rook B5 loses Rook B5
loses B4 no he
doesn't uh it's very
interesting
very interesting
indeed yeah Rook F5 Rook
B5
h
yeah not a lot of moves
here it's actually a funny position
let's go Rook
G3 we have a lot of pressure now on this
F6 Pawn as the the G Pawn is
spinned so he has to he has to figure
out how to play this we we might even be
looking at Rook captures on G7 point is
that if King captures maybe we can play
Rook captures on F6 and then if he gives
a check yeah he can't give a
check yeah it could be a move Rook
captures King captures Rook captures on
F6 and then what the king can go
to I don't I don't
see I don't see a very good move for him
after Rook captures on G7 so he probably
will even if he can't calculate this uh
he will probably just stop it just
play what
G5 yeah G5 is just weird we just we
don't even have to capture right away we
can even just play Rook back to
F3 and he can figure out what to do
about uh his Queen
side yeah it's so important when you're
low on time to not make some sort of a
uh critical judgment uh
error uh better you know keep your
options open just create some sort of a
threat that might not even be a threat
and let him burn time that's the that's
the proper way to do it so he plays King
h8 so the the idea being that he doesn't
want his G Pawn pinned but it it the
question Still Remains is Rook captures
and G7 winning I I stopped calculating
because I thought that he will prevent
it somehow but yeah okay R cap King
captures we can play Rook captures on F6
threaten all sorts of nasty discoveries
and then the only way to unpin would be
to play what if he goes King G8 or King
H7 is just lost either Rook F7 check or
Rook to G6 check so I don't see a way
for him to defend
this uh yeah I mean let's go for
it yeah the whole point is that after
King captures and Rook captures there's
no
check yeah looks uh looks ugly I was
inspired I I was inspired by we's game
today that I've shown on the channel
even though he was only 10 years old and
he played a much better game than I did
here
still uh you know uh sacrificing stuff
we'll we'll get you
places
probably I mean there's always a chance
I've blundered something here maybe
there is a defense and I just don't see
it uh but he's also burning time so I I
guess there there there isn't
one and now he's already you know in
danger of also being just flagged yeah
if you're you know if you're trying to
really you know always uh you know be be
a try hard try and win every game trying
not to lose every game I guess you could
flag your opponents yeah okay so he he
goes for Rook captur on B2 that makes
sense uh and now we have to figure out
how to play this yeah now this could be
yeah I actually haven't considered this
this is actually really good because now
after Rook captures he actually has Rook
to B1
check yeah that's pretty annoying oh
man but okay
uh yeah that's a good find yeah that's a
good
find but still I think we we got him I
still think we got
him Rook
G6 Rook G6 is the move yeah we we okay
so he goes for this yeah this is what we
had planned he cannot allow Rook
captures on H6 but now we have this this
and now if Queen captures we have Queen
captur so we don't have to worry and his
Rook is still hanging so yeah now we're
winning Rook F7 follow back Queen G7
will be made or we just take the rook
and we rob material he's much lower on
time yeah this is
resigns uh it's not uh not the cleanest
game uh I did mess up that middle game
uh probably completely uh because uh you
should not have this much trouble
playing Bop to B2 uh but I have no idea
what what I've done wrong so okay so he
resigns here we're going to briefly
analyze the game uh as we usually do so
good game uh Mr Mr
beus uh let's check out what we did okay
so E4 E5 this is all very standard stuff
Knight G5 the the two knights defense uh
all very standard okay and uh here okay
uh E4 Knights to E5 5 and Bishop to D6
okay the engine says Pawn to D4 uh I I
played Pawn to F4 both I believe can be
played probably D4 is a bit more precise
if you ask the engine but okay I played
captur captur he castled I played
castles also D4 can be played and Bishop
to G4 and I played the pawn to B3 yeah
here uh it would seem that against this
particular line of Bishop to G4 the
Knight to C3 is just more precise uh but
I went for B3 as I really wanted to put
my Bishop on this long diagonal and it's
uh yeah he
obviously well Bishop to C5 check King
H1 why why is this a question mark it's
a question mark because Knight to E4 is
just more precise okay so he's preparing
Bishop to C5 check that's the idea and I
have to sort of trade off the Bishops
with Bishop to A3 uh but still I mean
completely play I I I have no idea why
this is a question mark oh it's not a
question question mark it's a question
mark exclamation point so it's a sort of
a surprise move but okay King H1 he
played Knight E4 uh I played Queen E1
still a z z position so uh I'm pretty
sure it can be
played uh Rook to E8 all right we're
still sort of in the database people
have play played this uh D3 He played
Bishop captures I played Rook captures
so not captures he want
ah the engine suggesting G captures as
The Equalizer uh sort of G captures
Knight F2 check Rook captures and queen
H4 ah
okay
because if I play Rook F1 he takes I
take and Bishop F2 okay going after the
bishop here and I have to give up the
exchange this way so and Rook captures
on E2 and he will be up no I captured
the Knight and he captures the pawn wow
this is one ugly line and I have two
pieces for for The Rook okay I guess uh
yeah g captures could be more precise I
play Rook captures uh and he played
Bishop to D4 not Knight to F2 check yeah
he has to go for this um having to uh a
rook for two pieces although I don't
know I didn't like this for black one
bit so he played Bishop to D4 a double
question mark I counter it with C3 and
he played Knight captures
uh Rook captures on
E2 ah Bishop captures on H6 this is what
I missed Bishop captures on H6
deadly yeah threatening mate and he has
to play F6 and then Rook to G3 okay okay
of course if the bishop is captured then
just Rook to G3 check and the King hunt
begins yeah Rook the king to f8 Rook to
F1 with the queen coming to yeah
yeah missed that one uh not the best I
played Bishop to B2 double question mark
well of course it's a double question
mark I just threw away a free win uh but
still my position is better that's the
problem sometimes if uh there's nothing
wrong with your move you will easily
miss a far better move uh F6 okay Rook
to F1 Rook to B8 yeah also receives a
question mark I play Rook G3 precise uh
and he play King h8 yeah and now Rook
captures on G7 we found found the the
correct idea Rook Afters and G7 and he
also found the correct reply but Rook to
G6 counters it yeah and a rook captures
on F6 everything is uh everything is uh
played to to Perfection there's no
defense Rook to F7 check is coming uh uh
there there's really nothing to play
here like okay he gives this but yeah
we're not going to capture it still Rook
F7 check and after King G8 King captures
he will have a check here and after we
move now we threatening to win the queen
and after another check Rook to F3 and
okay yeah he will have to give up the
queen so this is uh the the best defense
that he had he would have a rook against
my queen but yeah he had 20 seconds on
the clock of course you're not uh
finding this or or playing this yeah
after Rook captures on F6 he resigned
and it was a it was a fine game I was
never really in any serious trouble uh
but uh yeah I I did BL I did miss that
Bishop captures an H6 move and it's a
weird weird thing to miss I did have a
rook on F3 I mean everything was there
uh what are you going to do you can't
see everything uh but yeah hopefully uh
I've helped some of you you know get
some ideas uh in your own games you know
what to think about when you're playing
some of my ideas are bad some of them
are terrible but uh you know if if
you're just starting out I will sort of
give you a general outline of what to
look for uh when uh considering moves uh
you know where to look on the board it's
uh so maybe if you're you are if you are
below let's say maybe 1,800 you will you
or maybe even less maybe even 1,600 you
could find Value uh in a in a video such
as this uh so yeah and a lot of you are
beginners a lot of you are only starting
your CH Journey so I imagine you uh will
find um this uh useful to to to an
extent uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it um glad to be back
with some uh daily rapid action un
leaches uh and yeah uh hope hope to see
you soon uh until next
time